et tout de suite c'est l'heure des
invités de paris direct
bonjour louise bonjour olivia ervi merci
à vous deux d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
la journée mondiale de lutte contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie et la
biphobie la raison pour laquelle nous
vous recevons donc c'est l'occasion de
cette journée internationale
louise vous avez été élu ici à paris
miss trans 2021 est originaire de la
réunion et vous représentez en gros là
la communauté française lgbt cui a
accueilli plus à l'étranger et puis
olivia ervi vous est notamment chargé de
mission afrique au comité idéaux france
idaho france pardon ong mobilisées
contre l'homophobie 1 un mot de vous
louise élus donc miss france lors du
grand bal des fiertés l'an dernier à
paris vous avez entamé votre transition
il ya il ya cinq ans je crois qu'est ce
qui vous a fait sauter le pas d'abord je
pense que c'est l'envi tout simplement
d'aller vers soi et de ne pas se renier
et à un moment donné je pense que dans
sa vie on a besoin de faire ce pas et
d'être justes soient ne plus tenir
compte justement du regard des autres et
et pouvoir s'épanouir tout simplement
parce que la vie est courte et je pense
qu'il faut pas en rater une minute donc
voilà et comment est-ce que ça a été
perçu autour de vous et et à la réunion
ça de autour de moi dans ma famille ça
n'a pas été une grande surprise parce
que c'est vrai que moi je suis artiste
je suis chanteuse auteure interprète et
déjà sur scène j'explorais déjà mon
identité de genre féminine après à la
réunion c'est vrai qu'on a cette chance
c'est une île où ou là diverses il vous
verriez vous là où voilà où on on a une
richesse une richesse culturelle aussi
qui est relativement énorme donc c'est
pas toujours évident c'est on va passer
on va pas se mentir maintenant je pense
que l'essentiel c'est aussi de trouver
la bonne façon d'amener d'amener les
choses de pas toujours non plus faire
trop de rentrer dedans parce que je
pense que l'humain n'est pas
nécessairement méchant il faut juste je
pense réussir à l'éduquer et à les
sensibiliser de manière peut-être
intelligente et voila voila et parler
d'homophobie parce qu'elle mopper dedans
et je pense que là la peur joue aussi à
la peur de l'inconnu probablement céder
chose c'est des sujets sur lesquels on
n'est pas forcément toujours habitués et
c'est vrai que si je parle de
transphobie par exemple de la trans
identité de manière générale il ya
encore une grosse méconnaissance du
public là dessus et essai et c'est vrai
que si on arrive à à déconstruire
justement c'est peut-être ses idées
préconçues qu'on peut avoir sur le sujet
on fait déjà un grand pas en avant dans
termes de sensibilisation et d'éducation
du grand public vous l'avez dit la
réunion c'est une terre d'ouverture sur
nombreux niveaux
la réunion est africaine même si elle en
est un petit peu éloigné calé dans
l'océan indien c'est quand même une
terre d'afrique et à quelques milliers
de kilomètres de là sur le continent les
situations sont sont assez disparates
olivia ervi
d'abord qu'elle est là quelle est votre
mission quelles sont les actions du
comité idaho france et notamment
concernant l'afrique alors les actions
du comité idaho france 5
enfin c'est très globale parce qu en
afrique la plupart des pays
criminalisent emprisonne les personnes
la communauté lgbt
idaho france en fait met l'accent sur la
protection
alexandre marcel
quand on a commencé à en parler il ya
quelques années
a décidé
de mettre en commun dia de mettre
l'accent sur la protection des personnes
qui criminalise quand ce n'est pas la
population qui adresse en des fois c'est
la machine étatique qui emprisonne des
fois à des peines très très lourd dans
des personnes pour suspicion
d'homosexualité jusqu'à 27 pays du
continent qui réprime l'homosexualité 4
la punissent même de deux morts un c'est
le cas au nigeria notamment
l'homosexualité notamment est un crime
aux au cameroun en guinée au sénégal au
togo au maroc en algérie en égypte en
tunisie au kenya et encore
bien d'autres il ya quand même quelques
progrès ils sont lents l'an dernier
c'est le botswana qui a dépénalisé
l'homosexualité est ce qui est de
l'espoir dans d'autres pays est ce que
les choses évoluent alors oui les choses
évoluent le gabon par exemple il ya un
an à dépénaliser
le bénin on est dans une tolérance parce
qu'on n'est pas emprisonné parce qu'un
homosexuel puisqu'il ya eu la
condamnation au bénin l'année dernière
des personnes qui ont agressé deux
jeunes entrant dans la rue ces personnes
a été condamné à six mois de prison ces
parias le cameroun je dirais qui a un
petit peu d'avancé parce que je n'ai pas
su me souvenais la sphère bijoux l'un
des agresseurs a été condamné par un
tribunal de yaoundé à six mois de prison
et un million trois cent mille francs
cfa d'un monte
pour moi ça a été moi j'étais dans la
salle puisque ça s'est passé au mois de
mars pour moi ça a été une grosse
émotion parce que je m'y attendais par
le cameroun c'est mon pays c'est à la
fois le pays où on criminalise on
emprisonne et pour la première fois de
l'histoire de mon pays de ma vie aussi
une personne a été condamné pour avoir
agressé
quelqu'un ne passe que la personne ne
correspond pas à ce que la société
attend d'elle cameroun où le travail de
madame n com est très important et fait
bouger les choses il ya les lois les
pays qui évolue mais il ya aussi les
mentalités et là c'est plus compliqué
par exemple illustration du sénégal où
il ya quelques mois il ya eu des
manifestations des manifestations
ouvertement homophobes contre un
changement de la loi comment est ce
qu'on fait pour faire changer les
mentalités y avait ces images de
manifestations à dakar de milliers de
personnes qui est très impressionnante
alors le plus terrible c'est quand les
imams parce que ce que l'appel des imams
à la population il met en place un
numéro vert
je sais pas si on peut imaginer s'était
servi sur son sol y ait eu tout à fait
pour l'aide pour la délation
les îles ont organisé sur la place
à dakar en cette manifestation pour
durcir les lois déjà au sénégal comme
beaucoup de pays y compris le cameroun
s'est on est passible de cinq ans de
prison si on est reconnu comme
homosexuels et pour eux c'est pas assez
peu pour les sénégalais enfin pour le et
même le gouvernement sénégalais je suis
désolé il ya quelques jours j'ai entendu
le discours de demain d'un aux tables
sénégalais par rapport à l'homosexualité
pour lui c'est un non événement pourquoi
est-ce que c'est chaud dans les
mentalités
on pourrait dire c'est un problème de
religion je ne pense pas se voir mais je
pense que c'est bon on parler
d'éducation tout à l'heure il est très
très important d'éduquer parce qu'ont
ramené tous libres et égaux ces pays
comme le cameroun a signé cette
convention des droits de l'homme qu'ils
ne respectent pas et la plupart des pays
ne respecte pas il serait temps je le
redis encore que la communauté
internationale puisse se pencher sur ces
exactions parce que ce sont ces sept un
crime
dans les états perpétue sur la sur leur
la population on peut pas mettre de côté
parce que je pense que en afrique on a
dans un pays comme le sénégal où le
cameroun on va dire 15% de la population
qui font partie la communauté lgbt et
séquences % doit vivre très caché
beaucoup ce mari
juste pour ne pas subir voilà enfin
qu'ils vont passer une vie en prison
c'est comme une double peine en fait
c'est le fait déjà d'être homosexuel et
de ne pas pouvoir l'assumer et ne serait
ce que vivra mais c'est vivre dans la
peur cette contrainte de 2,2 de dettes
marier pour ne pas attiser
attirer les des soupçons et surtout de
pouvoir vivre dans la clandestinité
éternellement donc lé loi il ya
l'opinion publique et puis aussi les
réseaux sociaux louise parce que c'est à
la fois une force pour faire entendre
des messages notamment de tolérance un
lieu de liberté d'expression et en même
temps c'est le lieu qui nourrit
l'homophobie alors oui c'est sûr que ça
à double tranchant et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention
ce qu'on peut lire sur sur les réseaux
moi par exemple j'ai pris le parti de ne
jamais lire les commentaires que ce soit
sur des articles ce soit sur les réseaux
parce que je sais que la haine et on
peut facilement cultivée cette haine
justement se cachant derrière un écran
et c'est tellement facile donc j'invite
véritablement les jeunes aujourd'hui on
est dans cette génération réseaux
sociaux à prendre beaucoup de recul par
rapport à ça c'est sûr que c'est un
endroit où on peut aussi s'informer
s'éduquer
se sentir moins seul c'est évident mais
en revanche il faut faire et je pense
qu'il faut apprendre à apprendre
énormément de deux auteurs justement
pour éviter des drames comme on a eu
encore il ya quelques jours avec
7,7 adolescents voilà transgenres qui
c'est qui s'est suicidée donc
voilà j'ai envie de véritablement les
jeunes à prendre beaucoup beaucoup de
hauteur par rapport à ça une dernière
chose et aussi des symboles et pas des
moindres il ya des espoirs même si c'est
pas en afrique il ya un message qui est
fort à l'international c'est karine jean
pierre qui a été nommé porte-parole de
la maison blanche aux états unis
première femme noire ouvertement lgbt a
occupé la fonction
de porte parole de la maison blanche aux
états unis qu'est ce que ça vous a fait
ce que c'est porteur d'un message bien
sûr c'est porteur d'un message c'est
important parce que on envoie les états
unis qui est une première puissance
mondiale en fois aux yeux du monde qu'on
peut être noir lesbiennes et avoir un
poste important dans un gouvernement
c'est très très important et en france
moi là je veux parler du coût pour la
france ce serait bien que le
gouvernement français puissent donner la
place aux personnes de la communauté pas
simplement une fois par an comme ça vite
fait campus éduquer dès
lors dans les collèges dans les collèges
et lycées parce que cela commence la
haine c'est là qu'on pense le rejet
après ça va être bien sûr sur les
réseaux sociaux mais je pense que faire
comprendre aux jeunes qu'on en a
simplement le droit d'être la personne
qu'on a envie d'être c'est très
important on peut pas
attendre le 17 mai pour en parler je
dois en parler le reste de l'année on
doit parler à nos jeunes nos enfants et
même certains adultes quillan pas été
qui ne connaissent pas parce qu'on a
peur de ce qu'on ne connaît pas voilà je
pense que les médias aussi ont un rôle
fondamental à jouer là-dedans en termes
de représentation notamment
parce que encore une fois je pense que
l'idée c'est véritablement de
déconstruire plus en fait on va avoir
des personnes qui ont un parcours entre
guillemets de vie normale et qui sont
qui font partie de cette communauté plus
on va justement déconstruire les clichés
et les stéréotypes liés à ces sujets
merci merci beaucoup appris à vous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous louise merci à olivia ervi aide est
revenu sur notre plateau aujourd'hui et
merci à vous d'avoir choisi france 24 on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
un nouveau journal a tout de suite
[Musique]